[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend rudi zerne ist mit mir im
Studio hat nachher den sportlichen Teil
der Sendung sehr gerne schönen guten
Abend dann verschaffen wir uns jetzt
gemeinsam einen
Überblick Flucht im gazaastreifen nach
dem evakuierungsaufruf der israelischen
Armee machen sich ztausende
Palästinenser auf den Weg in den
Süden Schlüsselrolle für Ägypten in
Kairo wirbt Außenministerin bärbock für
humanitäre Hilfe in Gaza Flüchtlinge von
dort will das Land aber nicht
aufnehmen vom Stummfilm bis zu aktuellen
Werken mehr als 120 Jahre deutsche
Filmgeschichte gibt's ab heute im
Weltkulturerbe Völklinger Hütte zu
sehen Außenministerin berbock hat bei
ihrem Besuch in Ägypten die
Terrororganisation Hamas erneut
aufgefordert die Geiseln freizulassen
unter ihnen auch acht deutsche
Staatsbürger innerhalb des Gazastreifens
fliehen Z vielleicht hunderttausende in
größter Sorge Richtung Süden weil sie
Wissen rund um die Grenzen ist
großflächig israelisches Militär
aufgezogen weitere Aktionen sind ja
angekündigt und werden vorbereitet wie
uns jetzt lü walpot
zeigt der kibut quasa auch eine Woche
nach der Hamas
Terrorattacke die Armee hier noch
Leichen von getöteten Angreifern das
Gebiet um den kibutz eine gefährliche
Sperrzone Hamas hat auch diese Woche
erneut versucht in Nachbarorte
vorzudringen die Grenze nach Gaza ist
nur 2 km entfernt Tag und Nacht sind
jetzt patruillen unterwegs aus der Luft
greift die israelische Armee auch heute
wieder Ziele in Gaza an wie hier in der
stadtunis im Süden des Streifens wo ein
iges Gebäude zerstört wurde Entsetzen
und Hilflosigkeit bei den
Bewohnern wir hörten im Schlaf diese
gewaltige Explosion unser Haus wurde nur
am Rand getroffen aber das Nebenhaus
komplett weggebombt unter den Trümmern
liegen noch
Opfer unterdessen fliehen tausende von
Gaza Stadt im Norden in den Süden des
Gebietes Israels Streitkräfte haben den
Menschen bis heute Nachmittag Zeit
gegeben sich in Sicherheit zu bringen
die Flüchtlinge sind verzweifelt es gibt
kaum Unterkünfte Lebensmittel oder Strom
Schulen dienen als
auffangzentren es war unglaublich
schwierig das kann man sich nicht
vorstellen wir mussten zu Fuß weg es gab
kein Auto mehr und überall
Raketen un Generalsekretär guteres
fordert dringend internationale
Hilfe wir brauchen sofort einen
humanitären Korridor Treibstoff Wasser
und Lebensmittel für die Menschen in Not
auch Kriege haben regeln
bislang warten Sie hier vergeblich auf
Hilfe wir gehen zu Michael bwerunge in
der Nähe des Gazastreifens Michael
weitere Militäraktionen werden
vorbereitet wie nah ist die israelische
Armee einer möglichen
Bodenoffensive ja wir haben heute diese
Bilder quasa gedreht die Sie gerade
gesehen haben dort wo vor einer Woche
besonders viele Menschen umgebracht
worden sind von has Terroristen und
viele als Geiseln genommen worden sind
jetzt patroulieren von dort aus die
israelischen Soldaten dieses
Niemandsland vor dem Gazastreifen und
man kann quasi schon hinübersehen zum
Gazastreifen wo heute umgekehrt
100ttausende 10ta000 auf der Flucht sind
ich habe mit einem humanitär einem
Mitarbeiter einer humanitären
Organisation gesprochen das Problem ist
für viele schlicht dass es gar keine
Fahrzeuge gibt um so viele Menschen mit
zu nehmen umgekehrt versucht die Hamas
am flüchten zu hindern fordert sie auf
zu bleiben Hamas Chef hanier hat heute
gesagt wir werden unser Land nicht
verlassen wir gehen auch nicht nach
Ägypten umgekehrt hat die israelische
Armee heute erklärt die Vorbereitungen
seinen abgeschlossen israel sei bereit
Gaza von der Luft von der Land und aus
der See anzugreifen also äh die
Evakuierung die ist auch die
evakuierungsfrist die heute Nachmittag
abgelaufen sind 4 Uhr die wird auch
nicht weiter verlängert werden es steht
nichts mehr zwischen der kommenden
Bodenoffensive sie wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwann jetzt mit heftigen
Bombardements beginnen danach wird die
Bodenoffensive Folgen danke schön
Michael bewerunge ja und inzwischen geht
die krisendiplomatie auch weiter nach
Ihrem Besuch in Israel ist
Außenministerin bbock nach Ägypten
gereist dorthin würden gerne tausende
aus Gaza flüchten und zwar über den
Grenzübergang Raffa das ist ganz im
Süden des Gazastreifens viele
Palästinenser warten hier und hoffen
rüber zu kommen aber die Grenze zu
Ägypten unüberwindbar der Nachbar will
den Flüchtenden keinen Unterschlupf
gewähren mehr dazu jetzt von Anna
Feist amerikanische Staatsbürger am
Grenzübergang Raffa im Süden von Gaza an
der Grenze zu Ägypten ihre Evakuierung
war Stunden zuvor noch angekündigt als
großer Erfolg westlicher Diplomatie doch
schließlich bricht Ägypten die Aktion ab
erst soll Israel Hilfslieferungen für
Gaza erlauben dann würden die Ägypter
auch die Grenze öffnen für die
Amerikaner für die palästinensische
Zivilbevölkerung aber werde die Grenze
zubleiben das machte der ägyptische
Präsident schon vor Tagen klar was die
Migration aus Gaza angeht das Risiko ist
zu hoch denn das würde der
palästinensischen Sache ein Ende
bereiten so sollen nun neue bet Klötze
helfen hunderttausende abzuhalten hinter
der Absage dürfte auch die Angst von
2008 stecken damals zerstörten die
Terroristen der Hamas die Grenzanlagen
zetausende Palästinenser kamen ins Land
radikale Islamisten verschanzten sich im
Sinai so steht in diesen Stunden Ägypten
vor einem Dilemma sie wollen
Hilfslieferungen von Ägypten nach Gaza
ermöglichen aber trotzdem sicherstellen
dass die Grenze für Menschen dicht ist
zumindest für die ohne westliche
Staatsbürgerschaft so geht das buen der
West Diplomaten in Ciro weiter nun zu
Besuch die deutsche Außenministerin die
Ministerin beteuert für die Zivilisten
in Gaza arbeiten sie und die UN an
Schutzräumen im Gazastreifen und was die
Evakuierung deutscher und europäischer
Doppelstaatler angeht das wird weiter
Thema bleiben mehr kann ich dazu an
dieser Stelle auch aus
Sicherheitsgründen nicht sagen vor
wenigen Minuten dazu die zynische
Antwort der Hamas die Terroristen
versichern dass sie alles unternehmen
werden die Zivilbevölkerung in gazaest
und soeben kam noch diese Meldung die
Bundeswehr soll deutsche aus Israel
Ausfliegen zwei Militärtransporter sind
derzeit auf dem Weg nach Tel Aviv so
heißt es aus Sicherheitskreisen für
morgen ist demnch ein weiterer Flug
geplant ja und wie geht es weiter in
Nahost die Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
ZF
heute halten Sie auf dem laufenden alles
was Sie wissen müssen wird immer wieder
aktualisiert in unserem Liveblog auf ZDF
heute die Ereignisse in Israel und im
Gazastreifen bewegen in Deutschland und
weltweit viele Menschen in Frankfurt am
Main hatte die jüdische Gemeinde
aufgerufen für Solidarität mit Israel zu
demonstrieren rund 3000 Menschen
versammelten sich vor der Paulskirche an
anderen Orten im Inn und Ausland gab es
auch proalästinensische Märsche in
London etwa versammelten sich mehrere
tausend Demonstranten zur Unterstützung
der Palästinenser
jetzt nach Polen wo morgen ein neues
Parlament gewählt wird eine Wahl die
auch für Deutschland und die EU große
Bedeutung hat auf der einen Seite steht
die Regierungspartei peace von Jaroslav
katinski die immer wieder mit der EU
überkreuz lag bei der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit oder der Migration
auf der anderen Seite Donald Tusk und
seine bürgerkoalition er will ein
liberaleres und europafreundliches Polen
letzte Umfragen sehen ein Rennen voraus
Andreas Kü
berichtet auf den letzten Metern dieses
Wahlkampfs der Polen gespalten genervt
und gelähmt hat kommt wirklich keiner
mehr vorbei an den Beschwörungen wählen
Sie eine neue Regierung wählen Sie die
Bürgerplattform wählen Sie Liste
7 nach 8 Jahren unter anderem in Brüssel
will Donald Tusk Chef der
Bürgerplattform noch einmal werden was
er schon zweimal war Ministerpräsident
Problem die die rechtsnationale
Regierungspartei stellt Tusk
unerbittlich als eine Marionette
Deutschlands Berlin rufen sie nach
[Applaus]
Berlin in buchstäblich jeder
Wahlkampfrede verkündet jarosw Kinski
der starke Mann der Pace das Tusk von
den deutschen kontrolliert werde und die
deutschen von den
Russen was bei dieser Wahl auf dem Spiel
steht ist wo die Entscheidungen
getroffen werden wird es ein starkes
Deutschland und ein starkes Moskau in
Polen geben oder ein starkes Polen in
Europa Donald Tusk verspricht die
Einflussnahme der Pace auf die Justiz
und das Fernsehen zurückzudrehen und die
Konfrontation mit der EU zu
beenden stimmt nicht für die peace ab
wenn ihr für die EU seid könnt ihr nicht
in den Umfragen liegt die
Bürgerplattform zwar deutlich hinter der
peace aber Tusk hofft mit etwas Glück
eine
Dreiparteienkoalition bilden zu können
Polen steht vor spannenden
Stunden jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine
dort hat sich die Kleinstadt aftiivka im
Osten zu einem neuen Zentrum heftiger
Kämpfe entwickelt die Ukrainer haben die
Frontstadt in der Region donjetk zur
Festung ausgebaut seit mehreren Tagen
versucht das russische Militär den Ort
einzukesseln und vom Nachschub
abzuschneiden in der Frage wie man die
Zuwanderung nach Deutschland begrenzen
kann sind sich bundländer und Opposition
näher gekommen nach einem Treffen
gestern Abend zwischen Bundeskanzler
Scholz den Ministerpräsidenten von
Hessen und Niedersachsen und cduchef
März sprachen alle Seiten von
konstruktiven Gesprächen beim nächsten
Treffen mit allen Ministerpräsidenten im
November sollen dann konkrete Lösungen
gefunden werden ja die Flüchtlingsfrage
ist momentan ein drängendes politisches
und gesellschaftliches Thema
Deutschlands einziger grüner
Ministerpräsident kritchmann sorgt sich
wegen der vielen die nach Deutschland
kommen über einen Rechtsruck und dass
die Grünen an Bedeutung verlieren wie
man mit diesem schweren Thema beim
grünen Landesparteitag umging dazu Eva
Schiller und jan-federik
Fischer sie ringen um einen Kurs in der
Migrationsfrage badenwürtembergs Grüne
wollen das Signal senden dass sie die
Sorgen der Menschen und Kommunen
verstanden haben der grünkonservative
Ministerpräsident versucht sich als
Vorreiter für eine schärfere grüne
Flüchtlingspolitik der Applaus mäßig
wenn wir im Namen der Humanität die
Aufnahme Bereitschaft der Gesellschaft
auf Dauer massiv überfordern dann werden
wir die Akzeptanz der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger verlieren die aktuelle Krise hat
die Wucht unser demokratisches
Gemeinwesen zu chüttern die Wahlen in
Bayern und Hessen müssten wegruf sein
Umfragen zufolge liegt die AFD in
Baden-Würtemberg bei 20% die CDU hat die
Grünen überholt und so bemüht sich auch
der aus Berlin angereiste bundesbesuch
um Rückendeckung es geht nicht darum
dass wir jetzt die Weinen da vor der Tür
stehen sonst dass wir die Ärmel
hochkrempeln und die Probleme lösen und
deshalb werden wir dafür kämpfen dass
auch der Bund stärker verlässlicher und
systematischer Eintritt für die
Finanzierung der kommun Grenzkontrollen
konsequenter abschieben Bezahlkarte für
geflüchtete bislang no Goos für liberale
grüne ich stehe kritisch dazu ich denke
wir müssen einfach auf unsere Werte
achten von der Parteispitze forder ich
dass sie da den Kurs korrigiert und wir
als Grüne weiter zu unserer DNA stehen
die heißt wir sind für eine menschliche
Asylpolitik da ist Widerspruch von
wenigen die Mehrheit steht notgedrungen
hinter Kretschmanns Schwenk in der
Asylpolitik für den Spagat zwischen
Menschlichkeit und ab
schreckung jetzt nach Australien da ist
eine Verfassungsänderung gescheitert die
den Ureinwohnern mehr Mitsprache im
Parlament sichern sollte das ist das
Ergebnis einer Volksbefragung unter den
18 Millionen Wahlberechtigten konkret
ging es darum dass indigen einen eigenen
Ausschuss bekommen sollten er hätte das
Parlament in Fragen beraten die die
Ureinwohner direkt betreffen aber eine
deutliche Mehrheit der Australier sprach
sich dagegen
aus
das Weltkulturerbe Völklinger Hütte im
Saarland ist Zeuge deutscher
Industriekultur und trifft ab heute
Abend auf ein Stück Kulturgeschichte die
Entwicklung des deutschen Films von
1895 bis heute in ungewöhnlichen
Räumlichkeiten in Szene gesetzt eine
Ausstellung die zeigt wie aktuell auch
Alter leinwondstoff sein kann Susanne
Freitag cateron hat sie sich
angeschaut es ist eine Art
geburtstagsempfang die Völklinger Hütte
wird
Bundespräsident frankwalter Steinmeier
gratuliert gefeiert wird mit einer
monumentalen Ausstellung auf über 100
leinwenden Flimmern 128 Jahre deutscher
Filmgeschichte die som das Grab der
Millionen der erste dokumentarische Film
von der Front im Ersten
Weltkrieg für Kaiser Gott und
Vaterland das ist derselbe Weltkrieg der
Film aber ist ganz neu vier Oskars gab
es in diesem Jahr für Westen nichts
Neues historischer Stoff beklemmend
aktuell das Ziel dieser Ausstellung ist
einersit natürlich Filmgeschichte zu
zeigen aber natürlich damit auch
Kulturgeschichte und Zeitgeschichte
Deutschlands eben in diesen 128
[Musik]
Jahren die drei von der Tankstelle
sollten die Bevölkerung 1930 von
Inflation und Kriegsangst ablenken fast
zeitgleich wurde der Film propagandain
inststrument der Nazis die umstrittene
Regisseurin len riefenstah TE auch in
Ihrem Auftrag die Verarbeitung des
Traumas zweiter Weltkrieg zieht sich
durch die
Filmgeschichte wir versuchen zu zeigen
dass der deutsche Film auch immer mit
der deutschen Geschichte gehadert hat
und mit den Bedingungen des Lebens in
Deutschland das heißt wir versuchen dem
deutschen Film ein Selbstbewusstsein zu
geben das ihm aber wie ich finde auch
zusteht bitte ermöglichen Sie uns die
störungsfreie Arbeit des
F auch die wiedereinigung natürlich
Filmthema Komödien Parodien Blockbuster
hier trifft Filmindustrie auf
Industriekultur ganz großes
Kino von Film kommen wir zur
Fußballgeschichte da wird neues Kapitel
aufgeschlagen ein mit Spannung
erwartetes debü Rud ein neuer Mann der
die Richtung voribt heute startet die eh
Julian nagelsmann bei der
Fußballnationalmannschaft zum ersten Mal
steht der neue Bundestrainer am
Spielfeldrand auf der USA testspielreise
trifft die Nationalelf ohne den
Erkrankten Josua Kimmich am Abend in
Hartford auf Gastgeber
USA das nicht überdachte Stadion in
Hartford verströmt einen ganz eigenen
Charm das Spiel ausverkauft 40.000
werden erwartet das Team von Coach greg
berhalter ist Weltranglisten damit ein
echter Prüfstein für die deutsche
Auswahl wir wissen dass Deutschland ein
gutes Team hat doch auch wir haben große
Chancen Julian nagelsmann wirkt vor
seiner Premiere nicht nervös eher
fokussiert dem Bundestrainer geht es vor
allem um die Art und Weise des
fußballerischen Vortrags das rein
Ergebnis steht heute nicht im
Vordergrund ich glaube wenn wir richtig
schlecht spielen und gewinnen ist nicht
gut wenn wir sehr sehr gut spielen und
nicht gewinnen ist es okay wenn wir sehr
sehr gut spielen und gewinnen das wäre
die beste und erfuichste Kombination
hier wird er zum ersten Mal das DFB Team
coachen an Sitzgelegenheiten mangelt es
nicht durch einen 2:1 Erfolg in
Amsterdam hat sich Frankreich bereits
nach sechs von acht Spieltagen für die
Fußball EM in Deutschland qualifiziert
die Niederlande hingegen stehen nach
einem imposanten Auftritt kilan mbappes
unter
Druck dem überragenden Spieler des
Abends gelingen um ein Haar drei Treffer
nur die Latte verhindert in der 6 Minute
ein weiteres Erfolgserlebnis mbappés an
der Begeisterung der französischen Fans
ändert das nichts bereits in der Sieb
minute die Führung Klaus auf mbappé
Frankreich früh auf em-kurs die jede
Champ darf dann auch ganz früh in der
zweiten Hälfte ein Tor des
ausnahmestürmers bejubeln und was für
eins mehr als den Treffer hatman zum 1:2
bringen die Niederlande danach nicht
mehr zustande wenn sie am Montag beim
Zweitplatzierten Griechenland verlieren
stehen sie extrem unter
Druck hast du gesehen de schon ganz in
dunkelblau ja du machst was richtig
danke Rudi zum Schluss haben wir noch
ein spektakuläres seltenes Schauspiel am
Himmel nämlich das Phänomen dass sich
der Mond vor die Sonne schiebt sie aber
nicht ganz verdeckt das Ergebnis eine
feuerkranzsonnenfinsternis der glühende
Stern als leuchtender Ring zu bestauen
in Teilen von nordmittel und Südamerika
etwa in Mexiko knapp 5 Minuten war der
Ring auf FE zu sehen und dann war's
wieder Licht bä vorbei so morgen kühl
und wechselhaft was danach kommt gleich
von Katja horneffer um 21 Uhr 45
empfehlen wir das heute journal mit Anne
gellineck schönen Dank schönen
Samstagabend und bis
[Musik]
morgen guten Abend jetzt ist der
Temperatursturz da denn eine Kaltfront
hat uns tatsächlich von Nordwest nach
Südost im Wesentlichen bereits über
quert da gab es auch kräftige Schauer
und Gewitter und Schauer und Gewitter
ziehen jetzt auch von der Nordseeküste
auf die werden uns auch noch in der
Nacht beschäftigen zum Teil ist der
Himmel auch mal nur locker bewölkt
länger regnet es noch am alprand und
diese Nachttemperaturen sind viel tiefer
als die der vergangene Nacht uns
erwarten 8° an der Nordsee und 0° in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen in Bayern aber
z.B auch in der Eifel oder im Hundsrück
reichts für Bodenfrost und auch morgen
bleibt es kühl die Höchsttemperaturen
liegen zwischen 7 und 12 gr und einzig
am oberrein geht's vielleicht auf 15°
drauf der Tag beginnt erstmal ganz
freundlich aber dann entwickeln sich
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter die sind
aber nur von kurzer Dauer bald kommt
dann auch wieder die Sonne zum Vorschein
der Wind ist nicht mehr so kräftig wie
heute er kommt aus westlichen bis
westnordwestlichen Richtungen und im
Südwesten macht sich schon ein neues
Hoch bemerkbar das Hoch Verena dort
wechseln Sonne und Wolken miteinander ab
am längsten regnend es noch am Alpenrand
die neue Woche startet kühl und meist
trocken bei 8 bis 5 10° schönes
Wochenende